I predicted this
um recently that the phenomenon of Abe
Simpson saying you know when I when I
was young I was with it then they
changed what it was and now what it is
is scary to me and it'll happen to you
too that's not going to happen to us
yeah and the reason is the millennial
generation is probably going to be the
biggest generation drop off that's it
it's before the top of the hill and uh
gen z may be a little bit bigger so
maybe it's gen Z but afterwards it's
going to get lower and smaller in the
populations already Contracting that's a
fact outside of any pandemics War World
War III or otherwise the future
Generations are smaller and smaller so
what's going to happen is Disney's
shifting Nostalgia marketing for one
simple reason they're like we got 30
million potential Millennials to sell to
or 10 million kids some of the older
Millennials there's more of them there's
more money if 10 million little kids
getting brought a dollar what are we
gonna get right if the Millennials come
they'll bring their kids we'll get even
more money Target The Nostalgia so that
means they're going to keep trying to
Pander to the millennial probably like a
range of millennial to Gen X with mostly
Millennial in the middle that's where
they're going to be targeting I don't
think people realize when you hit these
TFR total fertility rates like 1.2 1.3 I
mean the drop-off is significant and
Japan is just going to be suffering like
you know population decline in the
millions they already are same with
China China
all of Eastern Europe Western Europe
well so so uh we went to this haunted
house thing there was booze and there
was food and there was rides and it was
a little older crowd it was packed we go
to the theme park mostly for kids I mean
like there was a zip line there that I I
sat on and then I was hitting the ground
because they're like I'm just I'm a man
you know but I was well under the weight
limit well under and uh it's like it was
like a family thing and so we went there
and it was mostly kids but there was
like 30 in the whole place so where I
was just I was like yo where is
everybody
people don't have kids where are the
kids I don't know it was did it cost
money to get in yeah maybe they were
broke well you like you get a charge
card to do anything in the park and then
spend money like 30 bucks to get in or
something no no no like you get a card
and if you want to do anything you can
tap the card too so it's like you want
to play mini golf you tap it if you want
to go on a ride so it's free to get in
and then it's like pay per ride but you
can't do anything unless you get a card
it's just the signs of a Dying society
and then you have the other side of it
is that the the Millennials these young
adults they're just becoming
infantilized because they're not
progressing to the next stage of their
life you know with with a family or even
you know other things a business Etc
economic reasons intentionally
intentionally I mean look it's it's
great you have a smaller population to
control it's a lot easier than a
population growing that has to worry
about its posterity I mean you got these
leaders in in Europe like Merkel you
know she's not there anymore but none of
them had children so what do they care
what do they care about the future of
their their nation state whether it's
Germany or uh France whatever it is
Kamala doesn't have any children as well
does Justin Trudeau have any kids
I don't know I don't know probably
cousins in Cuba so I wonder if it's
these devices this is what Dr Phil was
saying oh yeah it's three kids
apparently um Dr Phil is like it's the
first generation of people raised on
these devices for instance 2007 that's
this and then you've got the fentanyl
that the Chinese are putting into the
Mexican cartels that are being shipped
up to destroy our culture that way I
don't know if that's the intention but
that's what's happening it's like the
Opium one did you guys the food supply
you guys see the viral video where it's
like this Tick Tock young teenage girl
gen Z girl being like my mom won't give
up her CDs and she's filming and she's
like this is my family's CD collection
and my mom won't get rid of them and
then her mom is standing she goes I am
not getting rid of them I got rid of my
albums then they came back I want my CDs
and she goes mom I can play any one of
these songs faster on my phone he goes
no it's because I don't remember these
bands you're like I like Oingo Boingo I
wouldn't even remember that they were
around unless I looked at the CD but
what's fascinating in that interaction
is the young kid
raised on the phone is like but I can
just play go and it's like you are too
young I suppose to understand no no I'm
sorry youth isn't the uh isn't the
reason for it you are lacking in context
and information there were people who
gave up their vinyl collections thinking
like vinyls going out the window vinyl
never died now all of a sudden they're
they're worth tremendous amounts of
money you go to these resale shops
antique shops and it's like the prices
are going up and up and up so so yeah
This Woman's like I'm not giving up
these CDs there's going to be a
Nostalgia Factor people are going to
want to pop those CDs in but she makes
another really good point yo when I put
on music on Pandora on Spotify I don't
even know half the bands that are
playing I don't grab my phone and then
type in music so that we don't know
phone numbers anymore right we don't
know phone numbers anymore but but the
main point is the commentary I saw on
this is you will own nothing and you
will be happy yeah this little kid is
like just rent the idea of music from
the machine mom what's the problem and
the mom's like I want my music that I
own tangible I like that you phrased it
that it was really the problem was the
ignorance of the kid uh it was the
ignorance of the human that was like
didn't realize the benefit of like if
they'd a vinyl because it's not gen Z
that's the problem it's the ignorance
and a lot of times kids are ignorant
just because they're kids and they don't
have the World experience yet some kids
actually aren't ignorant because they
have fantastic parents and some old
people are extremely ignorant you know
so it's not the youth that's the issue
but has any generation in human history
gone through so much technological
societal cultural change in such a short
period of time I mean these are things
that typically have happened over
centuries Millennia I mean if you look
at a a regular Joe schmoe from 1820 is
he that much different from 1720 1620
1520 I mean yeah there's things on the
margins but the change from say
post-world War II to today is on a scale
that we've never seen before and I feel
like it's almost evolutionary at this
point and I think it's leading to a lot
of the psychological issues we're seeing
a lot of the Mental Health crisis I mean
people can't cope with this change
they're just not it's not ingrained in
them yeah you would think that with
access to the world's information you'd
be able to solve every problem and then
every problem would be solved as a
result but just because we can does
obviously the test is shown doesn't mean
that we will correct uh yeah I think
this has been the most rapid advancement
in the human consciousness ever in the
history of and we and it's it's all
novel we don't know like where we make
fun of you know the Millennials the
Zoomers whatever they are but you know
there's really nothing to look back on
there's no historical point of reference
I hope what really happened is that like
aliens showed up at Roswell and then you
know it was an accident and they're like
ah crap meet with the government and
they're like we're gonna give you rapid
Communications technology to bring your
your people up to speed and they're like
all right and now the aliens are sitting
back laughing as if they gave chickens
like Ultra weapons and they're just
watching us be really done with it
they're like they're gonna wipe
themselves out with this data
impropriety you know right they're doing
people understand the the the
algorithmic manipulation I don't know I
don't know if it was Elon Musk has said
this said this I think was he said the
the current thing may actually be chosen
by an algorithm so there are people who
are like on the Trends on Twitter being
like I I like mustard ice cream and it's
like a robot just decided to promote
that one day and now you're marching and
locked up with it the algorithm is the
the new Holy Spirit of our world exactly
it's just touching things in different
ways but uh what what you were saying
before about you know how they're you
know
people aren't processing you know all
these new Innovations Etc I mean it's
the same way as looking at it as
um uh you know it it's it's like you you
get a new toy and it's just like you
know a new a new Gadget a new car and
you're just obsessed with it you're just
diving into it head first and that just
becomes part of you that's your whole
existence now and I feel like we're
seeing that on a generational scale it's
just this Obsession this Tech Focus it's
but everything that we've designed
whether it's all this access to
knowledge we're not becoming smarter
we're not solving problems all this
access to social networks communication
we're becoming more and more
disconnected more atomized it's all
having this counter effect I think one
of the issues that we're facing clearly
is that um there's just too many people
and we're not guiding reproductive
production wisely so maybe the first way
to do is maybe like a a great reset down
to like 500 million people that's the
right marketing term then we'll guide a
population uh reproduction uh what what
is what do the Guidestones say Luke I I
tried to do it no no the guys don't said
guide reproduction wisely or something
oh my God so the that's that's the idea
right the idea they know better everyone
knows better except us well the
algorithm is producing reproduction
digitally I like that you phrased that
that it's like the Holy Spirit the
algorithm is our current is that what
you said the whole yeah the Holy Spirit
yeah because imagine if someone owned
God and they were able to control it and
they knew what it was doing but no one
else knew what it was doing and make
everyone think and see one particular
thing when they want them to see it you
guys don't ban particular ideas against
that particular thing that they want you
to believe social engineering that's
god-like power you know be crazy you
know they've been trying to do this
augmented reality thing for a long time
right like Google Glass was like a
rudimentary version where you'd look up
to the right there's a little screen
there right now they've got the metapro
questioning and like the idea is they're
like goggles and you'll see the the real
world but it'll augment it
imagine in the future they tell
everybody
you know you can see through these
glasses you'll see everything like
normal and then you'll also see the
augmented reality stuff but the
augmented reality stuff is very easily
discernible from real life right the
graphics aren't as good until it's not
and then one day everybody sees the same
thing across the sky an explosion and
they don't realize it's actually a trick
in the augmented reality you see what
I'm saying or they don't want to take it
off because they take the glasses off
and everyone's fat ugly and miserable so
they put it back on everyone looks
beautiful what I'm saying is fake events
happen where everyone everyone thinks
with my AR goggles I choose what AR I
see so I'll load up my menu and I'll go
like this like this okay uh Facebook and
then you know Twitter and then tweet
send and then all of a sudden Kaboom
explosion in the sky and they think it's
reality but it's actually augmented
reality but everyone sees the same thing
reports seeing it and then everyone
assumes it really happened in fact yeah
yeah I've been noticing a trend on
Twitter the last couple weeks where at
the top you get that four you you big
thing and it says video about fill in
the blank was doctored experts say this
video recent video about White House
correspondent was doctored video was
doctored video was changed so like this
is like in the last two weeks I've
noticed this probably like four times or
five maybe four times that they're I
mean the age of deep fake is upon us
whether or not that's gonna be ar or
just actual video that we watch on TV we
don't even know or they'll accuse
fakes so there was a there was a story
in the press that uh Ron DeSantis met
with Clarence Thomas the day before the
Dobbs decision came down ending Roe v
Wade the real story was that a year and
a day before the media runs this story
without fact checking it and now the guy
who who wrote a secondary it was a
secondary source reporting so emails get
released by non-profit Raw Story writes
a story independent copies Raw Story
independent then realized oops we get it
wrong guy says I'm so embarrassed to
take it down but think about this
the defamation of lying about somebody
in an election is the cost of doing
business for these people if if you can
win a governor governorship for four
years is it not worth the 50 million
defamation lawsuit and man these races
cost more than that so you can these
we're getting to the point where
fetterman's campaign's been just making
things up imagine how dark it's going to
get I was on when I was on when I was on
Rogan's show it was like a year ago he
asked me how I felt about deep fakes and
I said I'm not I don't think it's going
to get that crazy I think it won't be no
no and now I'm like I was way wrong
they're going to make a deep fake and
it's going to be a grainy video of
Rhonda's supporters to make it look like
it's a cell phone so it's easily faked
and he's gonna say something not
ridiculous just kind of bad right the
the the real effective stuff is not
going to be Rhonda Sanders coming out
and screaming the n-word it's going to
be himself it's going to be him saying
something like look when it comes to
covid there's only so much you can do so
yeah are people gonna die a lot of of
people are gonna die I can't be bothered
with it all the time something like that
where it's like believable and there's
there's going to be a wild west period
as this Tech rapidly develops that
there's no legal precedent for the
defamation like you're saying so how are
they going to treat these deep fakes
what are the repercussions going to be
and it's going to be an insane period of
time before the law catches up if the
law and the regulatory system ever
catches up it may not these things are
going to appear in court yeah and then a
video not only that
a real video will appear in court and so
I'm like I filmed this guy punching a
dog and I'll say deep fake no one
believe it and then and then you're dude
it's this is a grand deep Victory call a
lawyer you you get your lawyer your
lawyer finds an expert and they said
your lawyer calls 10 experts here's the
video is it a defect nope that's real
okay expert number two is it Deepak no
it's real number three no four five
finally expert number ten looks like a
deep fake to me excellent you're hired
would you like to appear at this trial
then he shows up and says to the jury I
am a video expert I've been working for
20 years I watched the video it does not
seem genuine now this dude who actually
committed a crime could maybe even get
off to us just because the technology
exists so when we have experts in court
are we should we have to say how many
experts were interviewed and then how
many experts were chosen no of the 12
experts this the one that we chose says
this the other nine or eleven said this
that's not how it works I think we need
more transparency in our legal system
especially with software code and
apparently with experts end quote if
we're going to be putting people on the
stage what if what if okay let's how
about another scenario
a crazy uh extremist makes a deep fake
of you punching a dog you get arrested
you go to an expert and he goes you're
in a Crossland
from from Tim kiss uh I don't want to be
involved I I it's real it's real and
they go through nine experts who all say
the same thing like dude I don't I don't
I don't want to be targeted it's a real
video and then finally they get one guy
who goes I don't care what show you're
on Ian I watched the video I did the
analysis it's fake and then you go to
trial and they say but let's pull up the
nine other experts and they all go oh
it's a real video please please don't
burn my house down it's a real video
what what's sad about all this is we
could talk about you know the
theoretical implications of these deep
fake technology but you know you have
this media class that will publish
defamatory hit pieces without even using
deep fakes they'll just claim you said
something you believe something you are
something white supremacist racist Nazi
whatever and they don't need a deep fake
they'll just print it put in the
headline and that's what you are you're
branded and there's no recourse which
goes back to you know the state of our
defamation laws and it's only going to
get worse with the Deep fake it's only
going to get worse but it's pretty bad
right now and we have no solution thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there